foreign
[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist today
we're doing the ever popular Cosmic
queries Edition Chuck good to have you
man always a pleasure to be here you're
pre-loaded with Cosmic queries from our
patreon members and let me remind you
that it's patreon members and only
patreon members who ask questions so
what's the topic today we have
cosmological curiosity
enough of it you gotcha I got you
and if something I don't know I have to
call my people I got cosmology friends
just to be clear it's not cosmetology
that would be makeup and others
now that would be interesting
so what do you have all right let's
let's go to it with Danny K Danny K is
he from somewhere he's nope okay
Danny K from The Ether he goes good
morning gentlemen
uh of the court of knowledge and His
Majesty Neil deGrasse Tyson
dude we're going to answer your question
anyway you didn't have to
this is even though you are asking that
question first I don't know but and
actually he does put in here he goes I
am hailing from the Netherlands
Rotterdam
come to me and these humble inquiries of
knowledge
nederlands okay so what does he have
there he goes he goes in a previous
episode there was a mention of an
expanding of our universe and that there
could be a point in the distant future
where we would be stretched to a point
where our neighboring galaxies would be
too far to reach with this expansion
also affect our solar system as well
does it mean that our blue ball would
slowly drift away from our Star and
would our star dim before that time
comes and if so would you suggest uh how
we might be able to survive something
like this
we're all gonna die
foreign
yeah so in the vacuum of space there's
this mysterious pressure forcing an
acceleration of the expanding Universe
we have a word for it but we don't know
what it is we had no business naming it
really and it's called Dark Energy and I
joke that we should just you know dark
matter we don't know what that is either
we should just call it Fred and Wilma
you know just two words that don't hint
at anything physical right because we
don't really know what's causing it but
we can measure it and so this expansion
of the universe that's accelerating that
will continue to grow
and the bigger the universe is the more
vacuum there is and this pressure is a
property of the vacuum
so as the universe expands the gravity
gets thinner
the grab what we call the the gravity
density gets thinner but the the the
dark energy continues to grow relative
to the gravity so initially all the
galaxies will will expand beyond our
Horizon and then after that it will
start ripping apart the galaxies
themselves because that's a stronger
gravitational force holding them
together start ripping that apart and so
the solar systems will be flung hither
and yawn then it'll start ripping the
planets out of their solar systems then
it'll start ripping moons from their
host planets then it'll start ripping
planets apart
structurally then it'll start ripping
apart the molecules
then it'll start ripping apart the atoms
in the molecules then it'll rip apart
the nuclei of the atoms
then it'll reach the point where the
very pixels that comprise the fabric of
the universe
will succumb to this ripping Force
and it's called the Big Rip because we
do not know what will happen after that
moment at that moment the universe will
tear because it will no longer be able
to stretch in response to that Force we
call it the big rip and it will happen
if nothing else is in the way it's going
to happen in 22 billion years well well
there you go Timmy good night and you
sleep well hey have a nice day
have a nice day Timmy so so yeah the sun
will be long dead by then sun will give
up the ghost uh in about five billion
years we're about halfway through the
life expectancy of the Sun but so we'll
the sun will be dead long before that
happens and so I wouldn't worry about it
yeah there you go so that's the real
answer the real answer is Danny
exactly but I want to be around to watch
that rip that would be yes except I
would be in the universe that was
ripping and so I would be ripping apart
as well I live every day in a universe
that's ripping because nobody think
about it when you zoom in on a photo
that only works
until you start seeing the pixels right
that comprise the photo right if you
keep zooming in there's no more
information there but what happens if
you keep zooming in and you want to
break apart the pixels themselves what's
between them
who knows in between the pixels of the
photo that you're zooming in on and so
this is the this is the mystery and the
uncertainty we have in 22 billion years
I have it on my calendar by the way
as you say October 12th 22 billion years
now there you go that's very cool I
believe that's a Wednesday but yeah
thank you thank you Chuck the Savant
you pick any date 22 billion years from
now I'll tell you what day it's on
all right this is James booth and he
says my question is about dark gravity
okay I understand it which is what most
people would call dark dark matter but
he knows I'm calling it dark grab
because that's literally what it is it
is gravity and we have no idea what's
causing it it's not even black holes by
the way or unilluminated matter we have
good reason to know that that's the case
but go on he says uh most of the matter
we experience that makes up to stars of
Galaxy only makes up about five percent
of the content of the universe correct
okay if that's the case what you just
said it is is it possible that given we
interact with such a small percentage of
the universe we are indeed the anomaly
this really makes me feel weird yes yes
so it's imagine you're at night
and there's an ocean in front of you but
you don't really know it and you turn on
your light and you see these White Caps
okay which show up nicely under
moonlight
and
we are the white caps
of an ocean
that surrounds us
so correct we we are
if if there were beings made of Dark
Matter dark energy they would see us as
a contaminant in their universe that's
right yeah I know I know it's sad and
well yeah it is
not representative of the most common
stuff in the universe which by the way
is a violation of the copernican
principle copernican principle says that
we are not special in time or in place
or in location we're orbiting an average
star in an average Galaxy so
statistically it says that we're average
but if we are contained within that five
percent of all the laws of physics
chemistry biology and all the
ingredients that make up matter as we
know it then we are something unusual in
the universe but could we be the average
inside of the unusual yes we are yeah
yeah so I was going to complete the
thought and say given that we are
unusual rule we are average
there you go okay there you go very nice
very nice you know another example of
that is you don't have school systems
try to Corral all the smart people
together right or they used to do this
they put the smart people in their own
class okay all the AP kids are in
exactly exactly so in the in the general
population you're unusual because you're
like smarter than everybody else then
they put you in the AP class and now you
are just average you just average
that's right a problem I did not have
therefore that little bit of math was
something you didn't have to think about
not have to worry about that no I
remember okay so I was not in the smart
class in elementary school but I was in
the next class because they they totally
rank these classes and I and I remember
the kids in the smart class they got to
take French I'm talking about sixth
grade my elementary school before there
was middle schools that would absorb a
sixth grade they took French they had a
French person and I said they're
learning a foreign language and learning
how to smoke
two fourth graders sitting around
foreign
I don't know why but you bore me
why does every French person you imitate
smoke a cigarette why
it just works what what they they were
deciding
what you would be what you would learn
without me saying I want to learn it and
we're not measuring my ambitions for
what I could or could be in life and
this is for me that's that's a travesty
who who have we lost in the educational
system for want of an educational uh uh
program to identify where the ambitious
kids actually are versus those who
scored high on a test and more
importantly uh not just the ambitious
kids but what are identifying their
Ambitions because if you identify an
ambition you automatically excite the
person to learn exactly because they're
pursuing what they already like exactly
yes awesome stuck for president okay all
right next one this is let's go to uh uh
rotten Josh AKA
transmetal two hey guys uh this is Ron
Josh here from Summerfield Florida my
question instead of the Big Bang could
the universe have formed from a big
implosion instead of an outwards
explosion when I think of the big bang I
imagine exploding outwards so I was
thinking maybe it exploded inwards and
thank you for your time
before we had good data on the very
distant future history of the universe
right there was our equations that are
traceable to Einstein and others
including
um what's that dude's name
uh he was a Belgian priest actually who
contributed mightily to our
understanding of the big bang
and he so bang out so so
it under the Einstein's equations
it can sustain a collapsing universe as
well as an expanding universe so people
naturally said if we measure an
expanding Universe maybe it'll one day
recollapse and then start all over again
start all over yeah and that's where you
get this sort of
um these these these rhythms by the way
the name of that Belgian creases George
Le mate
yeah yeah and so he he took Einstein's
equations and said wait a minute this
can give us an expanding universe and if
we're expanding that means it had a
beginning if it had a beginning that's
interesting and then a lot of religious
people said oh a Catholic priest says
that in fact there was a beginning
because before then no one knew how to
think of a beginning of the universe it
was it was not a thought it's not that
they thought about it and said there
wasn't it's like of course the universe
was always here right how could
everything that there is have a
beginning so we have Einstein's
equations George lamantre says there's a
beginning and then everyone is jumping
on that saying see Genesis is true God's
made the beginning and so he said no
this ain't got nothing to do with
Genesis okay it was a little spat
between the religious folks who are who
were reaching for this scientific result
and the Catholic East who came up with
the result who was in denial of it
confirming biblical Genesis that's all
oh wow look at that and and he was
Catholic that's
kind of rough when your own people are
just like you know nah that's it's kind
of like if you appoint us you know a
special counsel and he goes yeah there
were no there was no fraud in this
election and you go yeah you're fired
[Laughter]
so anyhow so in that scenario until you
have data to show which version of these
what what variant on this equation is
operating you could have a cycling
universe and when I this is how old I am
when I was in graduate school we
explored all of these solutions to the
equation but we know now from data that
we're on a one-way trip the universe
will never recollapse so no we're not
going to have a collapsing universe and
the birth of the universe could it have
been a universe before that that
collapsed and then we get birthed us
again we don't know
okay well it would be hard to have a
collapsing system expand and then never
recollapse right you see what I'm saying
so uh because whatever made it collapse
should make it collapse again and
there's nothing out there that's going
to make that happen so interesting there
you go there you go hey nice question
man yeah way to go so this is Goud Goud
Hara gennadoni or how are gonna Dani
says this I'm from San Jose California
my question uh regarding shyness of dark
matter when interacting with other
matter if we think dark matter as a
giant spider web that holds the Earth
and the Sun and the gravity why does it
interact with dark matter that holds the
Earth and the moon together or the dark
matter that holds our solar system in
the Milky Way in the Galaxy with normal
matter these three spider webs would
scrape and break each other dark matter
is pretty outgoing all over the place
holding galaxies together and whatnot
but when it comes to interacting with
other dark matter why is it so bashful
is it because it's afraid of rejection
or maybe it's just not interested in a
three-way or whatever reason I'm just
curious please let me know uh you know I
think he was trying to do a bit at the
end here
trying to get a little bit at the end
you know but I I read it anyway just to
satisfy you you got your little comedy
bit in there yeah is there is there
different Dark Matter that's doing
different things yeah so dark matter is
not holding Earth together right the
molecular forces are the electromagnetic
attraction horses are dark matter is not
holding the solar system together all
the objects there is sufficient gravity
to make that happen uh but dark matter
is holding together the Galaxy and it's
holding together Galaxy clusters
so it turns out other than through
gravity
we don't interact with dark matter so
you could just walk through dark matter
you would know it and it wouldn't know
it more more accurately said you
wouldn't know it and it wouldn't care
okay so now not only do you not interact
with dark matter Dark Matter does not
interact with itself
because if it did you would have
concentrations of dark matter just think
about if you have two hot marshmallows
and they meet in the in at night okay
over the fire right what will they do
well they'll get it on because they're
both hot
I mean that sounds like a recipe for
marshmallow love if I ever heard it too
too hot marshmallows I'd come in the
game it was not my intent for you to
take it down that path so two hot
marshmallows they'll stick they'll stick
to each other okay so there are forces
within the marshmallow material forces
that when it sees other marshmallows
that they'll stick okay so we we our
matter knows how to do this all right
that's how you get planets that's how
you get Stars Right Dark Matter does not
stick to us so it's not with the
marshmallow or with the planet or with
the star and it doesn't stick to itself
so dark matter does not make
concentrations
so as far as we know and understand the
behavior of Dark Matter we're not
there's no you don't expect to see Dark
Matter planets the Dark Matter Galaxy
dark matter is the Unabomber it's just
loan it's a lone wolf
by itself by itself does not care okay
there it is at unibomber that's a
stretch I think but okay it was kind of
a Hermit right he didn't care about
anybody I mean listen I don't know
there's a morbid stretch I might add
more of it stretch but but anyhow so so
yeah it's just the fun the interesting
part is that it doesn't even interact
with itself physically only through the
force of gravity
nice so watch you have a forming solar
system and two bits of matter know this
and they fall towards each other and
stick all right right now watch we have
bits of dark matter all right and they
fall towards each other and they pass
through each pass through each other
right and and they'll just they'll just
rock very rude very rude very there you
have it oh very cool uh well that's a
great question man all right keep going
we're getting through these Chuck we're
getting through them with people uh have
made note that sometimes we take and
luxuriate in our question answers but
yeah no we're making progress here yep
so this is Bob Dan and uh bobden says
this hi this is Bob is from the US of a
if space in the universe is expanding
then why aren't we being stretched in
and ripped our part Adam by Adam and
what am I missing here I mean wouldn't
the expansion apply at every level goal
right down to the subatomic and how is
this current expansion different from
the so-called big rip you talk about and
here's what I want to know Bob Dan why
do you have such a damn attitude
you gave him the attitude I'm just
reading the way it's written no you you
are imbuing this boy's question with
Attitude okay I mean it's just I don't
know the way it sounds that he's I could
have read it peacefully and calmly I'm
sure okay that's true so so yeah so the
expansion of the universe
depending on the rate and where where
it's happening it will not overcome
the the gravitational forces that are
and the electromagnetic forces that are
otherwise binding solar systems and
objects together
the expansion of the universe has to be
way stronger
before that happened so in other words
yes you're stretching space but I'm
holding on to myself within the
stretching space until the force of the
expression space exceeds that of my
gravity or exceeds that of the electron
magnetic force then it'll pull you apart
so the fundamental forces of the
universe right now are greater than The
Ripping forces that are enacted correct
correct so you got it so the gravity if
you got a tight gravity system it's it's
you're not pulling that apart with your
expanding Universe yet cool yeah very
cool well I'm sorry for giving you so
much attitude I've read the question
it's a good question wait give me what
sentence had the most attitude there
read it to me okay okay and how is this
current expansion different from the
so-called big rip okay so I would read
that oh and how is this current
expansion different from the so-called
big rip see that's why you're an
astrophysicist and I have problems with
my um my my phone carrier okay
all right next question I'm just saying
I get on the phone with them and they're
just like sir you cannot talk to me that
way and I will not have uh I will not
right they can hang up on you and hang
up on you now you've used profanity
they'll just hang up they can hang up on
you now then there and it's totally fine
you know I don't ever use the questions
if it's Ai and you have the conference
will the AI hang up on you or will it
cuss you back and that's what I'll say
from now on I was just trying to figure
out if you were AI
[Laughter]
um anyway this is Michael Rivera Michael
Rivera says hello Dr Tyson and Lord nice
Michael here from Las Vegas my question
is would it be possible for humans to
artificially create a black hole with
significant mass in order to further
study the mysteries of how black holes
work and what they do if so how
dangerous would this be this artificial
black hole made here on Earth at a
sustainable size and would there be any
way of containing it this guy Michael I
have a feeling is trying to make a black
hole in his basement he's something
these basement people I worry about them
see I grew up in an apartment we don't
have any basement projects you know
hidden from the parents that's funny
Neil don't make me come in there I feel
like I hear a black hole being built
what's going on what would that side
[Music]
so
um yeah you wouldn't know how to contain
a black hole it's like Chuck pass me
that black hole Chuck where'd you go
oh that's funny
so yeah so you can't you can't we don't
know how to manipulate a black hole
right and so maybe someday we could like
Bunch up space time
and make a little container
out of I don't know I I don't know so
yeah this would be a really bad idea
because a black hole is a voracious
eater so let's say you had a black hole
on your desk and it fell to the floor
right they would start eating Earth
and it would just fall through Earth
eating anything that any part of Earth
that was near it and would continue to
do this until the entire Earth was
inside the black hole and you know how
big an earth Mass black hole is no about
the size of a plum oh that's that's
crazy that's yeah that that's a sad day
for Earth so yeah so your black hole
eating Earth
would become the size of a plum
wow that's the entire Earth fitting
inside the black hole right yeah look at
that oh man that's so cool like yeah
it's scary it's crunched down into a
something smaller than the size of my
fist yeah
it's very difficult to really conceive
when you think about it yeah because
you're limited to your five biological
senses exactly and the universe is
repeat with me under no obligation to
make sense to you there you go
and guess what it does a very good job
of that
okay it's winning in that battle as far
as I'm concerned all right this is
Captain James Reilly and Captain James
Riley you know we've gotten a lot of his
questions yeah Pat Riley Captain Riley
yeah uh he says why do galaxies form a
web or a sponge-shaped structure it
seems that on small scales gravity forms
spheres and discs so I'm a little
confused oh oh good question right the
large-scale structure of the universe is
not with galaxies equally spread it's
not with galaxies all in tidy spheres
although some Galaxy clusters are for
example the coma cluster of galaxies
this is a cluster of galaxies that lines
up with the Stars in the constellation
called coma okay a coma Bernie C so it's
the hair of Bernice okay so yeah if you
look at on Constellation maps from like
centuries ago when they used to draw
this stuff it's just somebody's hair
not to be confused with the comb over
commonly seen in boardrooms around
America
come over let's come over Galaxy
okay so the karma collection that's a
nicely spherical cluster of galaxies and
in fact that's the first Galaxy cluster
where Dark Matter was discovered
because you looked at all the the speeds
of the of the and there's a certain
amount of mass gravity required to keep
all of them in this in this ball whole
galaxies now thousands of galaxies I
think like maybe 800 I've got the exact
number but it's around a thousand
galaxies and many many hundreds and so
you calculate that up and you find out
that it needs like 10 times that much
mass
to keep the galaxies contained
if you add up the mass of every Galaxy
it doesn't add up to the gravity needed
to contain them so that was a kind of
Fritz Wiki in the 1930s 1936 I think it
was where keys of Caltech swiss-born
Caltech astrophysicist who who
discovered this and it's the longest
unsolved problem in modern astrophysics
the Dark Matter problem birth with his
observations anyhow there are some
Galaxy clusters that are nice
spherically shaped
others you see these filaments it's as
though you had a sponge and you cut it
and you looked at the cross section
where there's some concentrations of
sponge but mostly there are these sort
of bridges between concentrations that's
what the universe looks like the inside
cross section of a sponge here's the
problem
if you look at how fast the Galaxy is
moving
along one filament and look at the size
of the filament
the universe is not old enough for the
Galaxy to have crossed that filament
ah so you don't have structures that
represent what the galaxies really want
to do if they had enough time
so that's what's going on here
interesting right so that so you have
systems that are not gravitationally
um settled in what they should look the
coma cluster is all right and it's a
term we use for this I forgot it what is
it it's um a relaxed cluster is one
where okay we got this everybody's
orbiting just the way they should and
with this chill that's exactly and they
could cross the size of the cluster in
the time the universe has been around so
that how you know everybody's
everybody's settled into their routines
any structure is bigger than that they
have not had time to settle and so and
they may never settle given how long it
takes and given how fast the galaxies
are moving through space so yeah that
that's how and why we get that
wow
very cool
Lou pero says this violent tea or you
are you a-u-l-t oh peralt okay yes okay
he says uh hi Neil hadchuck my name is
Lou and I'm writing from the seven
islands
sceptiles he says in where are those
islands in Quebec
my question is is it possible to see
past by looking in the see the past by
looking into deep space and if so which
direction do we have to look and also is
it possible to see the Earth by sending
a telescope multiple light years away
yeah so only if you can travel faster
than light
can you see your own past so you so you
can't do that but what but
so I I know what he's saying but I want
to lead up to that so clearly
he knows that the farther out you look
the farther back in time you see right
okay so there are galaxies that are like
65 million light years away from Earth
okay from our galaxy wow so right now if
they had a super duper telescope and
they looked towards Earth what do they
see
if they're seeing us however many light
years ago 65 million years ago what are
they witnessing
uh dinosaurs right
oh and they're getting killed thank you
okay
it just died on me what that what that
time frame was there you go oh snap I
know I was putting on a show for him yes
so the Galaxy that's 65 million light
years away is witnessing the extinction
of the dinosaurs because that light is
only now just reaching them right okay
so but we
can't see our own past that that doesn't
work
so
um
so yeah but if you put if you send a
telescope out there
you know let's say a thousand light
years away
and then come back
it will be seeing whatever Happened Here
a thousand years ago
right
right yeah that's what's that simple so
so yeah that's it so and then what you'd
have to be like you say is faster than
the speed of light so that you can go
place it and come back and have and be
like yo what's up
what's up it's me
yeah all right so once you go fast and
speed like then all bets are off and
then you can do all kinds of paradoxy
things paradoxical things
cool all right uh this is Connor home he
says hi if the Big Rip does occur a lot
of big rip questions today people got it
on their mind man because because no one
wants to be
toward a thunder by the universe itself
no one wants to get
no one wants a new one torn into them
yes
I'm the universe boy
I will tell you a new one that's what I
will do you keep it you saw the word
Connor says if the big writ does occur
what would be the immediate results of
tearing of the fabric of space time
with these tears tears be black holes or
would they simply just be voids of
nothingness what is nothing how could
nothing come out of something
uh what what would these voids be wow
that's freaking crazy I love this Connor
okay so so my my simple answer is
we have no idea oh okay the state of the
universe posts big rip is a complete
mystery
and and what we don't know is is there's
some law of physics that will manifest
at that time think about that you know
when do we discover new laws of physics
when we step where we had never
previously stepped when we look where we
never previously looked when we bring a
new kind of apparatus a new kind of
detector that we've never had before
then we see the universe behaving in
waves we've never seen before sends us
back to the drawing board to say is this
understandable with previously known
physics or do we have to invent new
physics
so Einstein said to himself I don't
think we'll ever have a black hole even
though his own damn equations predicted
it because a black hole in his equations
have infinite density occupying zero
volume in the center of the black hole
and he said surely there's some new law
of physics that's going to show up and
save us from ourselves save us from this
mathematical craziness where God divides
by zero right right so what happens in
the Big Rip what would it look like we
do not know and I'd like to know before
that day happens so that we can like
protect ourselves if that's possible at
all we don't know and he's wondering if
it rips does nothing show up okay
something we call nothing something
that's called nothing okay but then what
is nothing what is
okay I think we have a whole explainer
on nothing
okay let me see what we got out of that
was there is no nothing
because because you know is is air
nothing well you can see through it but
we know it there's air there right so
clearly it's not nothing so now take
away the air
so what's left is that nothing well it's
still space
well it's empty space nothing and we
know from quantum physics that empty
space is a seething
soup of what we call virtual particles
popping in and out of existence
so and this is what we call the vacuum
energy you just Google that vacuum
energy there's an energy in the vacuum
of space that quantum physics puts there
and we thought hey that could be the
dark energy
in the vacuum of space so you do the
calculation for how much dark energy we
measure then you do the calculation for
how much how much pressure is coming in
from these uh virtual particles popping
in and out of existence and we are off
by 100 orders of magnitude
it is the biggest mismatch between an
observation and a theory that has ever
occurred
this is further evidence that we have no
clue what dark energy is okay wow so
so there it is now and could we imagine
a place where there's not even these
virtual particles okay but then you
can't have quantum physics
so all right so now we have a place
where there's not only not
nothing
there's not even the laws of physics
right whoa
so could you exist in that nothing yeah
because you only exist because they're
like molecules hold you together and you
know and light and energy and Electro
you only exist because the laws of the
same thing allow you to right so the
best nothing if the rip gets you there
if you step through that rip
maybe that nothing
does not even contain
the fabric of empty space
look at that because the laws of physics
tell us what the fabric of empty space
does
so if you take away not only the empty
space but the laws of physics that would
describe it
then that's as good enough thing as I
can imagine right and that nothing
exists inside of a bong
I've been there
tell you the bong nothing okay nothing
it's nothing wrong
so Chuck we have a couple minutes left I
think I'm gonna allow you
to give me one question even though you
you you're you're a cheap ass comedian
not paying your patreon dues uh
I was watching this uh thing on
listening to uh NPR and they were doing
this thing about energy and all the
different forms of energy and then they
for some reason played
uh a clip from what I know is one of
your and my favorite movies The Matrix
and they played the clip about how
the AI basically after a singularity saw
us as a form of energy to be used as
little batteries so my question to you
is do we put out enough energy that if I
if something were an AI would say you
know what I need to put them to work
and line us up head to toe
right so that we would become little
batteries as opposed to just taking us
and literally putting us to work by
subjugating us all and making us do
their will right right right right right
yeah I'm just trying to think if they
put you and me in a battery socket I say
no Chuck we got to be head to toe right
exactly you see the AI keep coming
around and flipping us
back I put it in the wrong way
go on the spring side right you know
what AI sounds like
that's an exasperated AI exactly that's
my AI that sounds like uh Chris Tucker
State man that's the beat go on the
spring side okay anyway
all right so
this energy described in The Matrix
draw is drawn from the human body so you
can look at our metabolism all right if
you're a calorie counter you'll know
that there's something called your basal
metabolism so this is the energy you
burn pay or play okay just for existence
just for existing right and for some
people it's maybe 1500 calories
a day for me it's more like a bigger so
for average I'm a little bigger than
average so like 2 000 calories a day is
my basal average okay so now
realize that the Food calorie
is written with a Capital C
you may not have noticed that
yes there's a reason for that because a
physics calorie is written with a
lowercase C
because a Food calorie One Food calorie
equals a thousand physics calories oh
okay so when I say I burn 2 000 calories
a day it's 2000 food calories it's 2
million
physics calories and what is a physics
calorie it's the amount of energy
required to raise the temperature of one
cubic centimeter of water
one degree Celsius
interesting that is one calorie that's
one calorie okay all right
so
once you have all these calories it's a
rate at which you're burning energy
we have a unit of measure for that it's
called Watts
okay
what
and so when you do the math on this
the average person
is operating anywhere between 50 and 100
Watts
okay okay so
it's like a light bulb you know like an
80 watt light bulb okay there's that 81
consumes energy at a rate so do we we we
radiate that okay well we consume that
much energy our circulation and
everything else so what the what the
what the machines did the computers did
in The Matrix is line us all up
and draw the 80 watts of power from
every person at all times
okay that's very inefficient so the
answer is yes that's how they did the
movie however
it's extremely inefficient yeah you know
why
because I don't want to power a City off
of light bulbs no no
no no no I used to light bulb as an
example
okay okay no no here's why it's
inefficient you're you're burning 2 000
calories a day
as long as what is happening as long as
I'm living and breathing no
yeah well yes but well yeah more
fundamental than that
well equally as fundamental as that
how long can you keep burning
2 000 calories a day
uh if that's I thought you said that was
my base yes that's your base
I gotta be eating something thank you
thank you
when you think those calories came from
the food you're eating so in order for
all of the Matrix people the people in
the pods to be feeding 80 watts of power
to the Matrix The Matrix has to feed
them
oh that's a lot of that's eight billion
mouths okay so what I'm saying is if the
Matrix is feeding you right 2 000
calories a day so that it can then pull
your 80 Watts off of you why why use the
middle man right just burn the cat burn
the food calories that you're feeding
the people in fact every time energy
changes from one form to another
it's not 100 efficient
you lose some energy to heat
all the time
right so you look at the energy in a
gallon of gasoline
okay and that gets burned to drive the
car
I forgot the number eighty percent of
that energy goes into heat
it does not go into moving your car
forward that's funny okay
so this is a fundamental feature of
thermodynamics in the universe
so they were being inefficient so this
is their weak point in the in their
storytelling and I will give them a hall
pass because they did everything else so
brilliantly but that one was just plain
stupid because the the machines the
computers just would use the food that
they're feeding them and get their
energy off of that and leave the people
out of it look at that but then they
wouldn't have had a movie
well you know that's a that's a problem
[Laughter]
yeah that makes things difficult yeah
yeah
all right that's that's all the time we
have Chuck okay that was fine what was
it this was Cosmic cosmological
curiosity a cosmic Aquarius cosmological
Curiosities I got it yeah like I got the
tongue twister all right Chuck always
good to have you here always a pleasure
all right this has been start talk
Cosmic queries cosmology Edition Neil
deGrasse Tyson here Ed Bowie's she's
looking at
[Music]